[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصها هاي شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
الصمود الاوكرانيه في باكو يكلفوا كييف
دفاعا عن شرسه في دنيتك وروسيا تقصف
امدادات اوكرانيه متجهه
بعد الاعدامات خطوات دبلوماسيه دوليه ضد
ايران والمرشد يدافع عن حمله القمع ويتتهم
المحتجين بالخونه
هدوئنا حذر في البرازيل بعد اعمال الشغب
السلطات تتعهد بمعاقبه المتورطين وتعزز
التاهب الامنيه في العاصمه
رغم الفضائح والعداوه بادره حسن نيه
منهاري تعيد خيار الصلح الى العلم فهل
تصفى النفوس بين الامير وعائلته
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
على طولي خطوط التماسي في دونياسك شرق
اوكرانيا تدور معارك وعنيفه بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه وامام الهجمات
الروسيه المكثفه لا يمكن الا ان تبقى
القوات الاوكرانيه صامده وتحافظ على خطها
الدفاعي في سوليدار وبخمر تلك المدينه
المدمر التي انهكتها ضربات الروسيه على
مدى سته اشهر متواصله لكنها صيد ثمين
بالنسبه للقوات المواليه لروسيا فحوله
مناجم الملح والجبس التي يحقق الاستلاء
عليها بلا شك مكاسبه ماليه كبيره
واستراتيجيا بخ مت هي البوابه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه شبه الوحيده لتقدم روسيا في عمق
دمياط خصوصا نحو المدن الرئيسيه الخاضعه
للسيطره الاوكرانيه
هل تسقط ضخموت في قبضه قوه الروسيه في ظل
احتدام المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني
الاخبار الوارده من هناك تفيد ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لازالت صامده لكنها تواجه
صعوبه امام الهجمات الروسيه الشرسه بقياده
قوه فاجنر ان الواضح ان جبهه القتال في
الشرق الاوكراني باتت الاكثر اشتعالا في
ظل رغبه روسيه واضحه في السيطره على باخم
والبلدات المجاوره لها ابرز هذه البلدات
المجاوره
» والتي تشهد حرب شوارع بين القوات
الروسيه
لكن الوضع الحالي لمدينه يبقى غامضه الفضل
لتضارب الانباء حيث تؤكد موسكو ان قواتها
تتقدم في عمق المدينه هذا في الوقت الذي
يقول فيه الجيش الاخراني ان صلد دار لا
تزال تحت سيطرته واذا كانت موسكو قد اكتفت
بالاشاره الى تقدمها في سندار فانها اكدت
سيطرتها على بلده بخمه ديسك التي لا تبعد
سوى تسعه كيلومترات
المدينه
استمرار المعارك الشمال دونيتك يواصلوا
الجيش الروسي قصف الامدادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه المتجهه من مدينه باخمط الى
بلده سوليدار وفي حصيله اوليه قتل العشرات
من الجنود الاوكرانيين خلال القصف
المستمره على الطريق السريع بين باخموس
وسوليدار فيما قصف الجيش الروسي الطريقه
السريع بالمدفعيه ورجمات الصواريخ
التطورات تتسارعوا اذا في الشرق الاوراني
في ظل الزحف الروسي المتواصل هناك وهو ما
دفع القوات الاوكرانيه الى تعزيز صفوفها
في منطقه الشرقيه بشكل عام سعيا منها
للتصدي للهجمات الروسيه المستمره والى
جانب هذه التعزيزات توجهها قائد القوات
البريه
العقيد اوليكساندر سيريسكي شخصيا الى ضخمه
وذلك لرفع معنويات الجيش ومتابعه اخر
التطورات
في المقابل وجهه القوات الروسيه ضربه
استهدفت فيها انظمه انظمه المدفعيه
الامريكيه تصنع وردرات مضاده للبطاريات
فيدوباز بحسب وزاره الدفاع ومن يذكر مبروك
مساء الخير صهيب بالفعل هي يعني هو المحور
الاكثر سخونه في المعارك هنا في الشرق
الاوكراني حيث ان
قواتنار والقوات الشيشانيه اضافه الى
القوات المواليه لروسيا من لوكانس تتقدم
من المحور الشمالي من اجل الوصول الى بعض
لكنها تتعرقل ااه بلده سلداره التي بعدت
تقدم فيها الاراضي بلده والاخرى
كما ان بلده
هي الاخيره ما زالت القوات الروسيه تتقدم
همم واسطه مواجهه او يعني صمود نوعا مال
الجيش الاوكراني لكن العنف في القصف
الروسي والمدفعيه كما ان سلاح الجو
الطيران الروسي ايضا يعمل من اجل التقدم
في هذا المحور والسيطر على بلده سندار
التي اا يعني تعتبر الطوق ال همم المكتمل
من الناحيه الشماليه
اذا تم السيطره عليها حيث ان القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على
المدينه همم
ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه كما ذكرت القوه
الاوكرانيه تحاول جاهده الصمود
الى متى سيستمر هذا الصمود خاصه في ظل
القصف الروسي همم كما تفضلت ولماذا يعني
كل هذه الاستماته للسيطره على باخره
بدايه يعني قطع الاتصال عن القوات
الاوكرانيه او المقاتلين على الجبهات من
القوات الاوكرانيه عن القواعد القياديه في
المركز في باخمط او حتى في المدن الاكبر
عبر استهداف القواعد
الاتصالاتيه المرتبطه
بالقمر الصناعي ستارلينج
ترك كثيرا على صمود هذه القوات الاوكرانيه
لان ليس لديها جهات اتصال مع القاعده
القياديه وذلك ما يجعل الجيش الروسي يتقدم
في هذا المحور وقت يعني قطع الامدادات
ايضا على الجيش الاوكراني كما اسلفت صهيب
حيث ان الطريق السريع ما بين وسليدار
تستهدفه والصواريخ والقذائف الروسيه
باستمرار هناك حديث عن قتل اكثر من 100
جندي بهذا المحور يعني المدينه تعتبر
استراتيجيه مدينه لانها هي المفتاح الرئيس
للدخول الى المدن الكبرى
المياه نهر الذي يعني يمنع المياه عن كل
المقاطعه لن يستلذلك تعتبر همم من اهم
المدن وهي الاكثر استراتيجيه حتى الان
رائد الاغبر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا
التحديث مباشره من دنياك
[موسيقى]
وبين ما تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاكرانيه
تستعد تستعد لتلقي دعم العسكري نوعين من
بريطانيا لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب اعلنت
بريطانيا ان الحكومه تدرس رساله 10 دبابات
من طرازه تشالنجر 2 البريطانيه لاوكرانيا
وهذا النوع من الدبابات يمكن ان يصيب
ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في الدقيقه الواحده
وتتميز بنظام الكترونيا للتحكم بالنيران
[موسيقى]
الدعم البريطاني بالدبابات هذا جاء في وقت
انحذرت فيه تقارير استخباراتيه البريطانيه
من استخدام روسيا اسلحه حديثه لتعزيز
قوتها الناريه في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
ابرزها استخدام طائرات سوخوي 57
[موسيقى]
تفرض الحرب في اوكرانيا
الجديده فمع استمرار الوصول الشحنات
الاسلحه الغربيه الى كيف بدات روسيا في
استخدام اسلحه حديثه ومتطوره وادخالها
لقوتها الناريه في ساحه الحرب لاول مره
تقرير لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اكد ان
روسيا استخدم الطائرات سوخوي 57 المتطوره
لاطلاق الصواريخ بعيده الماده من الاجواء
الروسيه على اهداف اوكرانيا
لكن بما تتميز هذه المقاتله هي من الجيل
الخامس لطائرات الاسرع من الصوت ثنائيه
المحرك دخلت الخدمه لاول مره عام 2020 في
القوات الجوف الفضائيه الروسيه تستخدمها
روسيا في تدمير شبكه الدفاع الجوي في
اوكرانيا
في تنفيذ مهمه متعدده
اكتشاف الاهداف على مدى اكثر من 400 كيلو
متر قادره على تتبع الستين هدفا في ان
الواحد
في خطوه تتخذها موسكو للرد على التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا ابرزه خطط دعمها بمنظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقطات المظهر
استخدام اوقات الصلاه 57 صاروخ كروز
الموجه تلفزيونيه ضد اهداف عسكريه في كيف
وتدميرها
وما اقدر بدخول الحرب في اوكرانيا عامها
الثاني تسعه اوكرانيا لتقويه دفاعاتها
وترسمتها العسكريه للحفاظ على اراضيها
والحد من التقدم الروسي
الغرب بمواصله الحرب
يفوق التوقعات
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اسرائيل تستعد
اكبر عمليه تهجير في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
من العواصم بعد احكام الاعدام الاخيره بحق
ثلاثه محتاجين في اصفهان حيث ادانت
المانيا استخدام السلطات الايرانيه لعقوبه
الاعدام ضد المتظاهرين مؤكده انها ستزيد
تكثيف الضغط على السلطات الايرانيه
باجراءات دوليه جديده كما اعلنت سبع دول
بينها المانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا بالاضافه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
طهران والقائمين بالاعمال لديها على خلفيه
حالات الاعدام التي باتت متكرره وحملتمع
وانت بصرف النظري عن النظام القانوني الذي
يتم بموجبه تنفيذ العقوبات والادراج من
ضمنها طلبت اليوم من السفير الايراني
الحضور الى وزاره الخارجيه من اجل توضيح
لا لبس فيه حول القمع والترويع الذين
يتعرض لهم الايرانيون وكذلك عمليتي
الاعدام الاخيرتين واللتين سيكون لهما
عواقب
من جانبيه
تتعامل مع المسؤولين عن اعمال الشغب
بطريقه عادله متهمه المحتجين بالخيانه
حماده حماده
كرم اوروبا
[موسيقى]
ليصل العدد الاجمالي الى 17 شخصا
تم تنفيذ اربعه منها لحد الان
محسن شيكاري
مجيد رضا رهنا ورده
[موسيقى]
دي كرامه
سيد محمد حسيني
[موسيقى]
جميل
فقط
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن دكتور ماهر دوت خنصري
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي دكتور اهلا بكم
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه
كيف ترى اثر كل هذه الاعدامات على زخم
وحجم الاحتجاجات في ايران
سوف تكون
لان الاستمرار في هذه الاعدام
لم يؤدي الا اثاره الايرانيين للتحرك ضد
النظام
وكذلك الظلم الذي يعاني منه الايرانيون
بسبب هذه المحاكمات الزعيفه اولئك الذين
اعدموا لم يحصل له على محاكمته منصفا وعلى
النيه كما انهم حرموا من اي دفاع وبالتالي
فانت ما يلجا النظام الى اعمال من هذا
القبيل ويعتقد انه يمكن ان يروي عن الشعب
ويسكته
وكل
ما اطاله امد الاحتجاجات
وكذلك تح المتظاهرين والذي يمكن ان يؤدي
الى المزيد من التدهور لكن هذا سيد خنصاري
داخليا همم خارجيا كذلك المجتمع الدولي
يراقب هذه الاعدامات بقلق ومجموعه من
الدول هي تلوح بعواقب ما عساها تكون هذه
العواقب وهل تغير من سلوك النظام الايراني
يا ترى
التي اصبحت على المحك الان وهي محل تساؤل
في البلدان الغربيه التي لم تتسائل اطلاق
الشرعيه همم هم لم يرغبون بهذا النظام
ولكنه رات بانها ان هذا النظام موجود ويجب
يتعامل معه ولكن الان وفي ظل استمرار
المظاهرات
وبسبب اعمال العنف التي يقوم بها النظام
في الشوارع او من خلال اعدام هؤلاء
المتظاهرين الاربعه وهناك اثنين اخران
ينتظران تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام كل هذه
التصرفات ااه مع وجود ايضا مئه شخص مهددين
بالاعدام عند ما ترى القوه الغربيه افع من
هذا القبيل فهي بالتاكيد تعبر عن السيائها
وهذا ما تم وبطريقه غير مسبوقه حيث ان
منظمات مثل الحرس الثوري الايراني ادرجت
على قائمه الارهاب وتم ايضا فرد عقوبات
لكن هذه تدابير لم تؤثر على النظام بشكل
فوريته
وقدرته على البقاء على الماده البعيد دون
ان يكون هناك تغييرات جوريه
معنا ساعود اليك بعد قليل بعد متابعه
القصه التاليه المتعلقه ايضا بالاحتجاجات
وبيحملت القمع كذلك كده مشاهدينا بعد ما
يقارب من اربعه اشهر على بدي الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه نسجل الاطباء الايرانيون شبكه
مخفيه لمساعده جرح الاحتجاجات الذين يتم
تعاقبهم في المستشفيات العامه فحولت بعض
المنازل تم تحويلها الى زيادات لاسعاف
الجرحى صحيفه جرور الفرنسيه نقلت عن طبيب
الايراني القوله ان المستشفيات الايرانيه
كانت تحت رقابه المشدده منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات ونقلت صحيفه في تقريرها ان
قوات الامن فتحت النار على مئات الاطباء
خلال مظاهرات سابقه لهم تضامنا مع
الاحتجاجات واوفقا للشهادات جمعتها
الصحيفه فان عناصر النظام يستهدفون عمدا
اجزاء حساسه من الجسم وعلى وجه الخصوص
الوجه واسفل البطن والساقين
دكتور خنصري في لندن اعود اليك كيف ترى
بدايه ما يقوم به الاطباء الايرانيون هنا
لتهريب الجرحى من اعين النظام
هاي بصراحه
ما قام به الاطباء لكنني اعلم ان كون
قواتي الامن استخدم
الرصاص الاستهدافي المتظاهرين في الوجه
وفي اسفل البطن
والاقدام اولئك الذين اصيبوا بالعمى عددهم
تزايد
ايران وهذا امر همم
الايرانيين وكذلك
ادى الى المزيد من المظاهرات لان هذا ينضم
لو يضاف الى حوالي 500 شخص قتل وما يقرب
من 20,000 ولكن
قبل ان يدركنا الوقت ما يقوم به الاطباء
هنا يجعلنا الا يجعلنا نتوقف ولا يعتبر
هذا اكبر دليل على ان ما نشهده ايران ليس
تحت جاجات عاديه بل هي فورا بدليل انه
الاطباء يقيمون مستشفيات ميدانيه دعنا
نقول في الخفاء لعلاج الجرحى
للاجنحه
في ايران هي اشارات ثوره ثوره شعب لم يرغب
في قبولي هذا النظام الذي يرفض ان يتعرض
للعقوبه ويتم تقديم الدعم للمصابين كل ما
الاعتبار من قوه
شكرا جزيلا لكم دكتور ماهر دار خنصري
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي كنت معنا من
لندن
[موسيقى]
قال مستشار الامن القومي ان الولايات
المتحده ستبحث مع اسرائيل تهديدات
الايرانيه مشيرا الى عزمه زياره اسرائيل
اضافه ايضا الى ان واشنطن تشارك تل ابيب
قلقها بشان تهديدات طهران لكنهما سيتبعان
سياسات مختلفه لمواجهه هذه التحديثات
وارجح سوليبا ان تكون ايران قد ساهمت في
ارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا عبر
مساعدتها العسكريه لروسيا
[موسيقى]
حضرت منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه من اقدام
اسرائيل على تنفيذ اكبر عمليه تهجير
جماعيه في الضفه الغربيه
وتجمعات من منطقه المسافر جنوب مدينه
الخليل وكانت منظمه بيت سالم الحقوقيه قد
وجهت رساله الى المدعي العام لمحكمه
الجنايات الدوليه طلبته فيها بالتدخل
العاجل لوقف مساعي عمليه التهجير
بد كلمات على مكعب اسمنتي كافيه لتغيير
القانون وتحديد مصير مئات العائلات
الفلسطينيه اما بالتهجير او انهاء الوجود
انها منطقه عسكريه مغلقه للتدريبات واطلاق
النار ممنوع الدخول
في المنطقه التي يمنع القانون العسكري
الاسرائيلي الدخول اليها عشرات التجمعات
الفلسطينيه عائلات تعيش هنا منذ مئات
السنين قصص وحكايا رجال ونساء واطفال
وبيوت هدمت مرات ومرات وظل اصحابها
يحاولون البقاء ان لم يكن فوق الارض فربما
تحتها كما يفعل عامر دبابسه الذي هدم بيته
واصيبت قدمه في اخره هجوم اسرائيلي ليذهب
لحفر مغاره وتجهيزها لاواء عائلته لعل
باطن الارض يرقيه شر سطحها المغاره
صعب حياه فيه بس لان انا بدي اتعايش مع
الوضع اللي انا فيه وبدي يعني اضل موجود
في ارضي سكان وخلت الضبع بضروره اخلاء
منازلهم وان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيبحث لهم
عن بديل بالاضافه ثمانيه تجمعات اخرى
يقطنها نحو الف نسمه اقرت المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه ان باستطاعه اسرائيل ان تضع
يدها عليها واخلائها كونها منطقه عسكريه
خاصه بالتدريبات بعمليات الهدم كانت
متكرره ترجع على الاشجار بدا يعني يطلع
فيها كانت متكرره عندك من الكهرباء المي
يعني اعدم كل شيء موجود للحياه فيعني اخر
شيء تعلق لك بموضوع المنطقه العسكريه
ومناطق تدريب الناس في هذه التجمعات لا
يصدقون ذريعه المنطقه العسكريه وخطرت
تدريبات لا سيما وهم يشاهدون المستوطنات
القريبه منهم تنمو وتتكاثر مؤسسات
الحقوقيه وقانونيه تسعى لمساعده السكان
بالتوجه الى المحاكم الدوليه
لثاني اسرائيل عن عمليه الاخلاء والتهجير
التي يبدو انها وشيكه مع ابلاغ الارتباط
الاسرائيلي نظيره الفلسطيني ان الناس سوف
يبلغون وقريبا بضروره الاخلاء وان اسرائيل
سوف تجد لهم بديلا اخر للعيش من منطقه
مسافر يطا عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الان الى البرازيل حيث عدد الهدوء
نسبيا الى شوارع العاصمه البرازيليه بعد
ليله عاصفه شهدت اقتحام مناصره الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق جرير سونارو مبنى
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا وقصر بلغته
الرئاسيه قبل ان تستعيد القوه الامنيه
سيطره على هذه المباني بعد التدخل الامنيا
طارق رئيس البرازيليه
لما قرات الفروع الثلاثه الحكوميه في
العاصمه كما استانف عمله في مكتبه في
العاصمه البرازيليه
[موسيقى]
وبعد عوده الهدوء بات الشغل الشاغل للرئيس
الجديد معاقبه المتورطين بعد هذا التجاوز
الخطير وهو ما تعهد به لويس سيلفا رفقه
رؤساء الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا في بيان
نشره الرئيس على صفحته في تويتر اذان دا
سيلفا في البيان المشترك هذه الاعمال التي
وصفها البيان بالارهابيه مشددا على ضروره
معاقبه المتورطين هذا واشار وزير العدل
فلافيودينو الى اعتقال نحو 200 شخص في
عقاب هذه الاحداث لحد الان
في ما وصف وزير الاتصالات البرازيليه
الاحداث الاخيره في بلاده ومهاجمه مقر
حكوميه بانها اشد خطوره من الاعتداء على
مبنى الكابتن في الولايات المتحده
اشد خطوره مما حدث في مبنى الكابيتول في
الولايات المتحده هناك لدينا هجوم على
المقر الحكوميه لكن بسبب الاستجابه
السريعه تمكننا من استعاده المباني
الثلاثه ونعمل على عوده الامور الى
طبيعتها في الكونغرس والقصر وسيكون كل شيء
جاهزا في غضون ساعه قليله
[موسيقى]
الامير هاري واصلوا تصدر العناوين في
بريطانيا بعد الهجوم الحاد الذي وجهه
لافراد العائله الملكيه سواء في مذكراته
او المقابله التلفزيونيه الاخيره لكن
السؤال المطروح الان هل يشق الصلح طريقه
بين هاري وعائلته بعد كل الذي حدث سينما
بدر منها
في تهمه العنصريه عن عائلته البعض فسرها
انها بادره حسن نيه منهار وعلى اي حال فان
الامير المحفي اكثر من مناسبه الى انفتاحه
على المصالحه مع العائله الملكيه فكره
المصالحه وردت في اكثر من مناسبه في حديث
الامير هاري حيث قال في وقت سابق انه يريد
ان يعيش ضمن عائله وليس مؤسسه كاشفا ان
عائلته لم تظهر اي رغبه على الاطلاق في
المصالحه الامير عاد مره اخرى الى الاشاره
الى استعداده للمصالحه قائلا ان الكره في
ملعب العائله وذلك في معرض ربه على سؤال
بصوا امكانيه حضوره حفله تتويج والده
الملك تشارلز الثالث واضاف هذه ان هناك
الكثير لمناقشته املا ان يكون افراد
العائله مستعدين للجلوس والتحدث عن ذلك
معنا من لندن دكتور احمد عجاج استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد اهلا بك معنا
في اخبار الساعه يعني كما غنت الست ام
كلثوم وعايزنا نرجع زي زمان قل للزمان
ارجع يا زمان هل يمكن ان يعود هذه الى
العائله الملكيه ام فات المعاد
من الصعب جدا ان يعود وهو اشترط العوده
بان يعتذر القصر عما حدث له وهذا صعب جدا
ان يحدث لكنه يحاول ان يمسك العصا من
المنتصف يعني بحاوله منه بان لا يفرض
العقد مع العائله المالكه والوقت نفسه
يستمر في الهجوم على العائله خصوصا وانما
كشفه ليس كثيرا لانه هناك مذكر لا تكتبه
زوجته ايضا وهذه ستكون ايضا مقلقه للعائله
للملكه اعتقد انه يعني هو رجل يعني بدا
حقيقه انه عانك كثيرا بسبب موت والدته ومن
المقابلات التي
في الجزء الثاني من هذه المقابله معك لو
سمحت ولكن اسالك كذلك عن العائله يعني في
النهايه هو امير والعائله الملكيه وكل
المشاكل هذه تحصل همم ولكن هناك مناسبه
هامه بعد اشهر تتويج الملك تشارلز رسميا
يعني معقول الامير هاري زوجته
ان يحضرات تتويج الملك
طبعا يعني هو يتمنى ان يحضر ويمكن ان
يدعوه الامير تشارلز لان الامير تشارلز
يدرك ان هذا ضروري جدا لكي لا يظهر بمظهر
الرجل الذي يترك ولده وهو كما قال الامير
هاري ان ان المؤسسه الملكه مثل هي مؤسسه
يعني العائله المالكه هي مؤسسه وولدته
قالت كذلك يعني الاميره ديانا كانت تصف
العائله المالكه بالشركه والمؤسسه والشركه
تعرف ما يناسبها وبالتالي لابد ان يدعوه
الى التتويج لكن لن يكون له المركز الذي
هو يتمنى ان يكون له وهذا شيء يتنشفه
الايام يعني في المستقبل ارجو ان تتفضل
معي دكتور احمد سعودي لكن نتوقف مع
تسريبات اخرى للامير هذه في مذكراته
الامير هاري في هذه المقابله التلفزيونيه
همم شنه هجوما على زوجه ابيه الملك
القرينه كامله كما اشار الى تصرفات عنصريه
قام فيها شقيقه الامير ويليام وزوجته همم
كيت همم مع زوجته
للصمت ان يجعل الامور افضل بنسبه الى
الامير البريطانيه جميعه من خلف اسوار
قصري باكنغام تحت المرمى نيراني
الملك القرينه وزوجته والده الملك ان شاء
الله
خطيره والشريره هجوم نيره خبراء محاوله من
تيار لكسب المزيد من التعاطف
اعتقد ان الظهور في صفحه الاولى جاء من
اعتقاد العائله الملكيه بان التغطيه
الاعلاميه الايجابيه ستحسن سمعتك ميله
وفرص قبولها كماليكا
بتبادل المعلومات مع الصحافه للحصول على
قصص ايجابيه مكتوبه عن نفسها لما كانها من
تحقيق لقبها الحالي
قرر هؤلاء الاعضاء التعاون مع الشيطان
لاعاده تحسين صورتهم
ثاني حاجه
الساحه لهاري لمهاجمه عائلته خلال سلسله
مقابله تلفزيونيه تسبق الصدور الرسمي
للكتابه
عن زوجته ضد اخيه ويليام وزوجته كيت قائلا
ان الالم الرذيذ
من عائلته الملكيه
مناعتهما من التعامل مع زوجته لانها ممثله
امريكيه مطلقه ثنائيه العراق
الصحف الغربيه كما البريطانيه تراقب مالات
تسريبات ومقابلات الامير البريطاني هاري
وما كشفت عنه من تنافر الاسري داخل
العائله الملكه لكن لقاءات الامير هاري
كشفت ما هو اكثر من مجرد خفايا القصر
الملكي بعضها تصريحات تناقضتهامات
العنصريه التي طالت العائله المالكه
البريطانيه في هذا السياق قالت المحلله
وكاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملك تشارلز
صحيفه القادمه
التي تمتلكها العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
قبول العامه بالنظام الملكي في البلاد
دكتور احمد عجاج يعود اليك في لندن ما هي
المشكله الحقيقيه بين هاري والعائله
الملكيه هل هي غير بين الاخوه مع ويليام
اييي مشكله مع زوجه الاب الملكه القرينه
كامله ااا يعني شعور بالتهميش ام زوجته
ربما
ميغا ماركل التي اتت من خارج المنظومه من
خارج التقاليد هي السبب ما سبب ما يحصل من
هذه البغضاء التي حصلت بين العائله
وجود هذا الشرق الكبير داخل الاسره الملكه
وهذا الشرق يعني ليس شيئا غير اعتيادي
العائله منذ وجودها وهي يعني فيها الكثير
من القال والقيل وهذا القال والقيل
والتداول الصحافه لا هو الذي يلقيها في
اعين الناس وفي ضمائر الناس وبدون هذه
الاضواء لا احد يعني يسمع عن العائله
الملكه لذلك هي ماده يعني مهمه للع الملكه
لكي تبقى على السنه الناس اما بالنسبه
للامير هاري فبالتضع هو رجل يعني بدا
حزينه وبدا رجلا يعني يشعر بانه قد ظلم
لكن بنفس الوقت يعني هناك كثير من التفاوت
في قصته وربما عندما نقرا كتابه غدا سينشر
سنعرف اكثر واكثر عن تفاصيل نظيف
كل هذه الضجه يعني لن تؤثر على مفهوم
الملكيه في بريطانيا لانه كان هناك يعني
نسمع بعض الاصوات صحيح هي خجوله التي يعني
تطالب باصلاحات في في النظام الملكي
البريطاني همم لن يؤثر هذا امطر انه
بالعكس يعني ربما ان تكون هذا الدعايه
اكثر للعائله المالكه بالنظر الى القصص
المشوقه التي تحصل الان
للملكه والعائله الملكه يعني بارعه في هذا
الامر هي التي نشرب الاثار والامير هاري
نفسه ويكسب من وراء ذلك لانه حصل على 20
مليون جنيه والدليل على ان الاسماء اتكلمت
تاثر اعيدك الى الاميره داني ديانا التي
قال في مقابلاتها ان الامير شارلز لا
يستحق ان يكون ملكا وارادت من خلال تلك
المقابله ان تؤلم الراي العام عليه لكن
انظر الان الامير تشارلز يتوج ملكه
جمال واصبح الملكا صحيح شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور احمد عجاج استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
مباشره من لندن
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد نهائي اخر
قيود الجائحه اكبر مقاطعه الصين تسجل 90
مليون اصابه بكرونا خلال ايام
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد التوتر
الهدف من هذه المناورات يقول الجيش الصيني
هو اختبار القدره على التصدي للاعمال
الاستفزازيه للقوى الخارجيه والقوه
الانفصاليه المطالبه باستقلال تايوان
الاخيره وفي ربها على هذه التدريبات اكدت
انها لن تثير الصراعات لكنها ستدافع عن
سيادتها واملها
التوتر المتزايد بين الصين وتايوان
المدعومه من واشنطن يفتح الباب امام
سيناريوهات متعدده من بينها المواجهه
العسكريه بهذا الخصوص اوردت شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه تقريرا لمركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه الدوليه اجرى خلاله محاكاه
للاصطدام العسكري في حال شنت الصين عمليه
عسكريه ضد تايوان وخلص المركز الى ان اي
عمليه عسكريه للصين لن تنتهي بسيطرتها على
تايوان في ظل الدعم القوي الذي تتلقاه
تايتباي من حلفائها على راسهم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكن التقرير تتوقع ان
تكون خسائر الجيش الصيني والامريكي فابحه
للغايه
[موسيقى]
الصين التي ودعت اخر قيود كورونا والسفر
لا تزال و تشهد انتشارا غير مسموح للوباء
في مقاطعه قنا
بالسكان اصيب نحو 90% من سكانها فيروس
كورونا وهذا يعني ان حوالي 88.5 مليون شخص
قد اصيب بالفعل من بين سكان المقاطعه
البالغه عددهم حوالي 100 مليون نسمه منذ
بدايه يناير الجاري عدد الاصابات بشكل
هائل واحدث ضغطا كبيرا على المستشفيات
التي لم تعد تستوعب اعداد المصابين
[موسيقى]
اعتمد الرئيس الامريكي
على الاقل خلال الايام العشره الماضيه
فيما تسببت العواصف وانقطاع الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
الصمود
يكلفوا كيف دفاع شريصان
[موسيقى]
والمرشد يدافع عن حمله القمع ويتهم
المحتجين بالخيانه
هدوء حذرا في البرازيل بعد عمل الشغب
السلطات تتعهد بمعاقبه المتورطين وتعزز
التاهب الامنيه في العاصمه
رغم الفضائح والعداوه بادره حسن نيه
منهاري تعيد خيار الصلح الى العلم فهل
تصفى النفوس بين الامير والعائله الملكيه
شكرا لكم على كرامه المشاهده دائما المزيد
يبقى على العربيه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]